hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so it's
been a while for me sorry i've been
pretty busy but let's
today solve leak code 42 trapping rain
water
so we're given an integer array
representing the
heights of certain elevations or
whatever right so
it's a one-dimensional array the first
value is zero
meaning a height of zero so that's over
here the next value is one so that means
a height of
one some have heights of two this one
has a height of two
this one has a height of three right and
so given this
entire structure we basically want to
know how like what's the
maximum amount of rain water could
this structure trap right given an
unlimited amount of
rain so you can see this is one unit
right over here
this is roughly four units right
one two three four and then this is
another one right so when you count all
of those you get a total of
six squares right so the output is six
this can trap a maximum of six blocks of
water
so with a picture it's pretty easy but
what how do you
know right like what's the algorithm to
determine how much
each position could trap right like for
example
this position is the first one right so
there's no
boundary on the left of it right so no
matter how much
water we would add over here it would
all just spill
to the left and the same is true for
this position right no matter how much
water we put on top of here even though
there's a right boundary over here right
there's nothing on the left of it so all
the water is just going to spill out to
the left so it's not going to trap any
water
but you can see in the third position we
are able to
trap exactly one block of water so
what's the algorithm to determine why is
it one
right because we care about the height
because we want to know how much water
and it's actually pretty simple right
take a look so here we have
one block of water what if i added a
second block of water
well we can see that there is a boundary
on the right this is good right
but what about the left side there's no
boundary over here right meaning
any water i add is just going to spill
out the boundary only has a height of
one so we're seeing that the height on
the left is one the height on the right
is two so we're
we need to take the minimum of that we
need to take the minimum of one and two
because that
is our bottleneck that is what's
determining
exactly how much water we are able to
trap
per position right for every single
position we need
the max height on the left and the max
height on the right left and right and
then we need to take the minimum
of those two let's take a look at this
position clearly we can't trap any water
here but
why exactly is that the case well when
you look at the right position right
in the entire right section the maximum
height is a
three right so that's good three here
what's the maximum height on the left
side
it's a one right this position
is a two if we take the minimum of one
and three we get
one so that's our boundary that doesn't
mean we can trap
any water here we can trap zero water
here the reason is
because the actual calculation is we're
gonna take the minimum
we're gonna take the minimum of the
maximum left height and the maximum
right height we're gonna take the
minimum of those two and
we're going to take the height that
we're currently at right so let's say
h of the index i that we're at
so this is the equation we're going to
use to determine at every single
position
i let's say this is our i position right
so you can see i is in this equation
this is going to determine how much
water we can trap
in position i so we know the minimum of
the
max of the left and right right because
the left was one the right was three the
minimum of those is just going to be
one and h of i so the height at position
i
is two over here right two so we're
gonna take one
minus two that's actually going to give
us a negative
number right that's going to give us
negative 1
but we know we can't trap negative water
right so we're always going to round
up we're never going to use negative
numbers because it doesn't really make
sense
to trap negative water over here so
really since the
solution is negative that really means
that we can trap
zero water in this position but let's
just
move to a couple more positions before
you probably get the idea so over here
right
in this position the height is one right
and the max height on the left is two
the max height on the right is three
again right so we take the minimum of
two and three
so we're going to get two right two is
the minimum
and height of i is one right the height
at this position
is one so that means we can trap exactly
one water in this position
right clearly that is the case right
we're trapping one unit of water
and basically if you did this exact same
calculation
for every single position including this
position you'd get
the appropriate water count so this
position would give us
two units of water this is going to give
us one
these are going to give us zero this is
going to give us one and the rest are
going to give us
zero water that we can trap once we take
the sum of all those we are going to get
our answer
six so now let me actually show you the
efficient ways to
solve this problem okay so i'm going to
show you two different ways to solve
this problem
both of the solutions are linear time
solutions right so big o
of n is going to be the time complexity
of the solution
but the first solution i show you is
going to actually require big
o and of memory as well there's an
actual optimization you can do with two
pointers
to reduce the memory from linear memory
big o of n
to constant memory so i'm going to show
you both
of the solutions and it's actually not a
lot of code the code is actually pretty
easy
since for every single position right to
know how much water we can trap at index
i we need to know what's the max
left and right height of every single
position right so for this position the
max on the left is going to be 2
right over here and the max on the right
is going to be 3
right over here right so we're going to
need to be doing that calculation a lot
so we can actually make an array and
then store
that calculation for us so that we only
have to do it
a single time each so first we can scan
through the array right just go iterate
through the entire array
calculating every single max left
position meaning
for this position what's the max height
on the left of it
well there aren't any heights on the
left of it so it's going to be zero
what's the max height of this well the
max height is
zero right that's the only height that
came before it what's the max height
on the left of this well it's a one
right so
we can do this in linear time big o of n
time so i'm just gonna do that right
what's the max height on the left of
this
one max height on the left of this we
have a new max it's two
right we just keep track of what the
current max is so far
right now it's two two we got a new
height a new maximum that's three so now
three
is going to be the max left height for
the remainder of these
right so we calculated the max left
height we can actually calculate the max
right height pretty easily as well when
we iterate through this
in reverse order right we go from right
to left
so initially the max right height is
zero because there's nothing on the
right of this
next it's going to be one now it's going
to be two
and now we got to a three so the max
right height for the
remainder of this is just going to be 3.
and remember we actually need to take
the minimum of the max
left and the max right for every single
position right so for this position we
want the minimum
of these two values for this position
right
zero we want the minimum of these two
values right
because the minimum is going to help us
determine how much
water we can trap in this position right
and clearly we can actually find the
minimum of these two arrays as well
in linear time so here is the minimum is
zero
minimum is zero minimum is one one two
two one and zero
and so now for every single position
we're going to determine how much
water we can trap and we can do that
remember with our calculation we can
take the minimum
of the left and the right and subtract
from it the height at position i right
and we're always going to round
up we always want it to be greater than
or equal to zero and then we can add the
sum
of all of those values and then get the
total water that we can trap
so in this position we have zero minus
zero minus zero right so here the amount
of water we can trap
is zero here we have zero
minus one that's going to be negative
one but we don't count negative so
the amount of water we can trap here is
zero here we have
one minus zero the height at this
position so we can actually trap
one water in this position here
we have one minus two that's going to be
negative
so we can't trap any water here here we
have
two minus one so that's going to be one
that means we can trap
one water here this is two
so the maximum boundary is two minus
zero that means we can trap two units of
water here
next position we have a two minus one we
can trap
one water here here we have two minus
three that's going to be negative
we can't trap any water here this is
going to be
2 minus 2 again 0 water that we can trap
here
2 minus 1 that's
1. so we can trap one unit of water here
here we're gonna get
one minus two that's negative can't trap
any water here
here we have zero minus one that's also
negative so can't trap
any water here and that makes sense why
would be we why would we be able to trap
water here when there's no
right boundary but okay so we have all
of our values we take one plus one plus
two
plus one plus one and
we get exactly what we expected right we
get a six
we can trap six units of water here so
this is the solution
taking extra linear memory okay so
now i'm going to show you the o of one
memory solution it's still linear time
big o of n time but this time we're not
gonna need any of this
extra memory that we just allocated
we're actually gonna do this
we're gonna do this with two pointers so
initially i'm gonna have my left
pointer over here i'm gonna have my
right pointer here
so the right pointer is going to be all
the way at the end of the
input array so we're going to have our
two pointers initialized we're also
going to have two variables
max left and max right which are going
to be keeping track of the maximum
left pointer and maximum right pointer
so far so you can see
left is initially zero so the max so far
on the left is zero
you can see right is initially one so
the max on the right so far
is one so now we are gonna have to
update our pointer now which pointer are
we gonna shift
we're gonna take the one that has the
smaller max
value so right now you can see max
left has zero max right has one so we're
going to shift the smaller one
which is left so we're going to take our
left pointer and shift it
so now our left pointer is over here and
just
just uh fyi we know that we can't have
any water stored on the end points right
on the left and the right
positions we can't have any water
because they're endpoints right they
can't contain any water
but this position technically can have
some water
and how are we going to determine that
well we're going to take our
how much water this can contain right
we're going to take the max
left value that we have in our variable
right now right
how how come we don't need the right
value
well i'm going to show you so this is
the part that you kind of need to notice
the trick
i guess right so we're in this position
right
now remember originally we wanted the
minimum down here you can see we wanted
the minimum of the max
left and max right well we know what the
max left
is so far right the max left is zero
right that's what's over here
now we technically don't know what the
max right is even though this variable
says
one yes so far it's one
but we know that the max right could
actually be three
right that's what the true max right is
of this position right because there's a
three over here
so why is it that we don't need that
value
because remember we want the minimum of
the max
left and the max right now we clearly
know that the max
left is zero right so it's smaller
than what's even at this position right
and we want the minimum
of it so no matter how big this value is
right right now it's a three it could be
a 10
right it doesn't matter how big it is
because we want the max of the left
and the right and we already know that
the left
is pretty small right it's it's zero
so it doesn't matter what's in all of
these values
because we know that the max left is our
bottleneck right remember we
shifted our left pointer from here
to the next position because left
was smaller than right that's why we
shifted it
that's how we're able to calculate the
water that's trapped in this position
without knowing what the max right is
so with that being explained let's
actually go through this so we can get
to the code
so what's the amount of water that we
can trap over here it's actually
zero because the max left which is the
value that we need is zero right so zero
minus what the actual height is in this
position is
one we know that's going to be a
negative one we don't count negative
ones
so we're not gonna use that so we're
gonna say that zero water can be trapped
here
but you can see look this is a one right
our left pointer is here so we can
actually
update this we can cross the zero out
max left is now actually going to be one
so now we're actually at a dilemma right
because take a look our max
left and our max right are both one so
it doesn't really matter which one we
shift let's just shift
the left one again so we're shifting our
left pointer over here now right
and since they're equal this is going to
be the bottleneck which is
left pointer and the max left and it's
one so far
so no matter how big anything over here
is we know that one is gonna be the
bottleneck
we're gonna do one which is the max left
pointer or the minimum of the max of the
left and right pointers right
so we're gonna take that one minus the
value that's
in this position the height of the index
i
which is zero so that's going to give us
a water
level that is one so that means
in this position we can store one block
of water so basically i'm running
through the
algorithm with two pointers so i'm just
going to quickly go through the rest of
what this example would be
so again we're going to shift our left
pointer because left and right are equal
so it doesn't matter which one we shift
we're shifting the left one over here
so now to calculate how much water would
be stored
here we're gonna take the max left
pointer which is one
and subtract from it the height that's
in this position
two that's clearly negative negative one
so what we're gonna say
is that zero water could be stored here
and so since we reached a height of two
that means we can update max
left and set it to two now so now
remember we wanna shift the minimum
pointer and right now the minimum
pointer is
the the right pointer which is a max
height of one so we're going to take our
right pointer and shift it
and since we shift the shift to the
right pointer now we have to calculate
the height
or the water that we can contain in this
position right
and so remember now the bottleneck right
is going to be this the max right height
for this position
is one right so it doesn't matter how
big heights over here are right there's
a three here but we don't care about
that because the max
right height is one and remember we're
taking the minimum of
the max left and right height so
no matter what we do that's always going
to be 1 for this position
so we're going to take 1 minus the
height in this position which is 2.
that's obviously going to be negative so
we don't have any water here so we can
say
zero water here and since this is a two
that means we can also update our max
right height now to two so this is going
to be set to
two now the max right height is 2. and
since they're now once again equal
they're both set to 2
i'm going to be updating the left
pointer because it doesn't really matter
which one we do
okay so let's calculate the water in
this position so we're at a left
position so we're going to take the max
left height which is 2 minus the height
in this position
1 that's going to give us a 1 meaning
that we can contain
1 unit of water and the height in this
position is 1 so we don't update our max
left height but we can now shift our
left pointer one more position
now our left pointer is over here our
max
left height stayed the same it's two so
let's compute the water we can store
here
two which is you know the boundary uh
subtracted by
the level here which is zero so that's
going to give us
two units of water that we can store
here so a two here
and let's shift our left pointer again
because the max left and right
are equal so now we're over here what's
the max left it's still
two minus the height in this position
which is one
that's going to give us a one so that
means one unit of water can be stored
here
let's shift our left pointer again
awesome so now our left pointer is
actually at
a three so what we're going to do is 2
which is the max
left height minus 3 which is the height
in this position that's going to give us
a negative right so what that tells us
is that we can't store any water here
that's a zero
right but you can see our max left
height can actually be
updated now right it's going to be set
to three now
so this is a little bit messy but let's
just say our max
left height is three right and our max
right height is still two remember we're
shifting the minimum
height so we're taking now the right
height and shifting it so now
we can take so we're at a right position
we can take the max right which is 2
subtract it from the height in this
position 2 minus one is going to give us
a one that means we can store one unit
of water here
now let's shift our right pointer again
because two
is less than three so now we're
basically at the last
position right so the the max right
height is two
the height in this position is two so
what we're gonna do is two minus two
that's gonna be zero right so we can't
store
any water here that's gonna be a zero
and now you can see
we filled in the the water levels that
we wanted right when you take this
one plus one plus two plus one plus one
once again you're going to get the total
six right because
six is the amount of water that we can
store i just show you
showed you now how to actually do it
without any extra memory right we took
away this big chunk of memory that we
were using
and we did it with two pointers and if
it doesn't make
a ton of sense right now it might make
even more sense when you take a look at
the code
which is actually shorter than you would
expect let me show you that right now
so one short edge case we have to take
care of is if not height meaning the
input is
empty we can return zero this is needed
for this problem
and just like in the explanation i'm
going to initialize
two pointers left is going to be at the
beginning so index 0
and right is going to be at the last
index so length
of height minus 1.
i'm also going to have two maxes so the
left max and
the right max which are initially going
to be set to
height of the respective indices so
height of left
height of right i'm also going to have a
result which is going to total the water
for us
so i'm gonna run this loop while
left is less than right so before they
meet each other
and remember we're gonna decide which
cell to compute
and which pointer to shift depending on
the comparison between the maxes so if
left max is less than right max
then we're going to be shifting the left
pointer otherwise we're going to shift
the right pointer so if left max is
smaller we're going to increment left by
one in the opposite case we're going to
decrement
right by one and remember we're also
going to be
updating the the left max right so which
is so if we get to let's say compare
left max with
the current height at position left
right so whichever is greater we're
going to be updating the left max
with that value and we're going to do
similarly
in the opposite case so right max would
also be updated to the max
of itself and the new height that we get
to height r
and remember so in this case right we're
going to be taking the left
max and then subtracting the height at
the position i
or the position l right at the left
pointer position
right so we're going to be making this
computation right
and then we're going to be adding that
to the result
right so this is going to be added to
the result
now notice how i'm not making any check
to check that this
is negative because technically this is
never going to be negative
and you can dig into that if you want
it's because i'm updating the left max
here
before i'm doing this computation but if
you were to swap the order of these two
you would
need to make sure that you're not adding
a negative to the result but that's just
a minor detail that you can probably
confirm on your own
the bulk of this is that you have to
take the left max and then subtract it
from the height
at that current position right and so in
the else condition we're going to be
doing the opposite we're going to be
adding to the result
the difference between the right max and
the height at the right pointer
so this is really what i was just doing
in the picture
right this probably makes it a little
more clear because we actually have
good uh variable names and stuff but
yeah
after all this is done the last thing
that you have to do is just return the
result let me just prove to you that it
runs
and runs efficiently and you can see
that it does exactly that so i hope that
this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot i showed you
how to do this in linear time and
constant memory
complexity